lamar jackson in his second nfl season
became the nfl's mvp but no one wants to
be the regular season mvp they want to
be the super bowl mvp peter king spoke
with both lamar jackson and his head
coach john harbaugh here is some of what
peter had to talk about with the mvp and
the guy who some would say was the coach
of the year in 2019.
did you watch the super bowl last year
um no i didn't
i watched the highlights after the game
why didn't you why didn't you watch i
felt like we should have been there you
know like we worked so hard throughout
the season
and to fall short unexpectedly is like
i don't want to watch that i feel like
we should be there
do you remember what you did that day on
super bowl sunday
uh i think i was i was on break like
because you know down there i had to we
did the mvp thing then i had to run
around and do do stuff
and i was like i need to pray today like
i don't want to go nowhere i probably
like snap a little bit that day i'll
just chill
that was interesting because you were
awarded the mvp basically in your
hometown
how did that feel
oh it felt good but i really didn't want
to be there because i want to be
somewhere else like getting prepared for
the super bowl instead of winning the
award like i'd rather have a speech on
video like i'm sorry i couldn't be there
because because you know
game but i had to be there i really
didn't want to be on stage so it is what
it is
football is the ultimate team sport
peter and uh and i would say lamar
jackson is the ultimate team player i
mean that that's exactly how he sees it
now you're right you know someday
he's going to look back on that and
that's that's going to be one of those
moments that man he's going to cherish
it
when he was i saw him beforehand we
happened to be
there was different stages for these
different events and i was down there
and i was walking
with some friends
and we were we were coming across the
hotel and i saw lamar standing with his
mom in front of his hotel which was next
to the hotel that we were at
and uh and he was waiting for the car to
pick him up to take him to whatever he
had to go to
and he had he had his he had his like
his orange or purple jacket with the
with the
the the the lion or the the
african wild dog in the back
uh
and he was like he had this look on his
face like he was tolerating this and his
mom has big smile on her face you know
so i i feel like you know it was he got
it more than he did because you know
she's she's our age he's been down the
roads a little bit and understands the
meaning of it but lamar
he he enjoyed it and it did mean
something to him but and i think to his
teammates you know because he did feel
like
they were part of it he said that but
now man he was just he was he even said
a coach coach kill him we got to be
playing we got to be playing in this
game we should be playing in this game
that's all he carries around with him
you know 24 7.
of course as a coach i love it
john harbaugh and lamar jackson i
misspoke earlier harbaugh officially was
the coach of the year i can never quite
remember who the official award winners
are for some of these that are close
because by the time we get to the night
before the super bowl i don't care
anymore and i think that's what makes
this presentation so awkward chris it's
been 20 years since the regular season
mvp
was the super bowl mvp a lot of these
regular season mvps are available to
attend the ceremony the night before the
super bowl because they're not playing
in the super bowl lamar jackson just the
latest in a fairly long line of that and
yeah of course he doesn't like it it's
unsatisfying and when you look at what's
happened with the ravens the past couple
of years they get to the playoffs and
they lose in their first game and it's
dangerously close to becoming a
narrative if it happens again this year
and it's going to put more pressure on
them this year i remember when the
bengals were going through it you know
hey marvin lewis you've now lost three
straight playoff games hey marvin lewis
you've now lost four playoffs david hey
marv you know it's bigger and bigger
every time you get back they have to
kill this thing dead
the next time they're in the playoffs
and they likely will be this year yeah
well agreed i mean first off he should
you know it's a special award nfl mvp
damn i mean that's pretty big time there
will be a point in his life when he does
really appreciate that but every player
wants to be on the big stage of the
super bowl there's no stage that can
compete with that you know and to win
the mvp on that stage is yeah you're
more glorified in the you know in the in
the history books to win the mvp on that
stage as compared to the regular season
certainly but i'm with you mike i mean
you've been you've been banging this
drum
my dad was on my podcast with me last
thursday he brought up this same subject
that you know if baltimore
again is the team we think they are
because i think they're probably the
most talented team in football top to
bottom on the roster if we get halfway
through the year we get into november
and it goes oh here we go baltimore's
going to the playoffs they're one of the
better teams that is all we are going to
talk about
that is going to be the talk i mean last
year going into the playoffs we and i
were having the same conversation with
desean watson right you know you would
you were saying it well they lost that
first year to the colts they lose again
this year we're going to be talking
about deshaun watson's own two in the
playoffs and can't win the big game and
blah blah well he won one he was in
danger of losing that one but here we
are with lamar jackson and i think what
like makes it a bigger conversation too
is
you know is the fact that he's still
developing as a as a pocket quarterback
and we know that we need to see that a
little bit
especially in playoff football because
most times in playoff football you're
playing a defense that's smart well
coach and they take away some of those
running things and everything like that
so it is going to be a story and they're
going to have to answer it only one way
and that's win a damn playoff game and
shut everybody up
and really find a way to manage that
pressure and that stress and you know
what maybe this year one of the benefits
if you don't have media in your building
every day if you don't you know it's
going to feel a little more sterile than
usual and some of those outside
influences that would become palpable as
you get closer to the playoffs and
that's the thing when you get to the
playoffs everything grows more media is
present you feel it you you know you
sense it maybe if they can just continue
to go about their business and playoff
week feels no different than a regular
season week that that may be one of
those things that helps them
psychologically just treat it like a
normal game the more you make it a big
game chris the greater the chance
you're going to realize when you're out
there what the stakes are and maybe you
you press a little bit too hard you
could have the ball a little bit longer
you're too careful because you know if
you lose this one it's done everything
you worked for it's over i agreed i
think that's you know mike i think you
kind of hit the nail on the head that's
what happened to baltimore you know big
moments
you know oh hey here's a high pass lamar
jackson ball gets tipped in the
interception you know holding the ball
oh fumble right before the half strip
sack fumble titan score touchdown kind
of game over you know
john harbaugh going forward on fourth
down a few times that i didn't
necessarily agree with but i think that
all went into like kind of what you're
saying mike they were kind of like in
shell shock they were like what what's
going on here we're in a game we've been
steamrolling everybody for like 10 weeks
in a row and i feel like that did hit
them and hopefully they can learn from
it and battle through those and and you
know learn how to manage the game to
what you're saying to where it doesn't
get away from them like we saw two years
in a row basically and then all of a
sudden they got some you know a lot of
cheap yards at the end of both games to
make the game look a little bit more
competitive than it actually was
and if you clinch the one seed with one
or two regular season games left maybe
you don't take your foot off the gas we
saw what happened last year and i think
that was one of the factors as well
three weeks for the key starters
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports